Carnegie Mellon is a special University
shaped by its
distinctive history
we were founded by Andrew Carnegie a
Scotsman who came to the city of
Pittsburgh in America where he created
one of the world's great companies and
one of its great universities now this
American institution founded by a
Scotsman more than a century ago is
writing a new chapter in its history as
we become a global university and
graduate our first class in Doha in
Qatar on the shores of the Arabian Gulf
and as we do so we are creating new
traditions by honoring the nation of
Qatar by playing it's beautiful national
anthem even as we honor our old ones by
wearing our academic gowns with its
Scottish tartan all of this stuff and by
playing the bagpipes and the American
National Anthem we are so pleased and
proud to welcome the superb group of our
new graduates into the ranks of the more
than 72,000 proud Carnegie Mellon alumni
around the world and i would like to
especially thank and congratulate the
family and friends who have done so much
to help and support these graduates
during their years at carnegie mellon i
know you share their feelings of pride
and happiness today as you should you
have entrusted us with your most valued
treasure your children and we deeply
appreciate the confidence you have shown
in our faculty and our staff your
children have been challenged to think
deeply and critically and broadly and we
believe that is essential to progress
and positive
change they will be tomorrow's leaders
in business industry government and
academia they have not only been the
pioneers of Carnegie Mellon in Qatar
they are the pioneers of a nation the
young people in which Qatar and its
visionary leadership have placed great
hope the faculty who are the heart of
this great university also deserve our
recognition and thanks for all they have
done to challenge the minds of these
graduates and prepare them for future
contributions to their professions and
communities you our students soon-to-be
graduates have heard a lot over the last
four years about being pioneers and
builders you arrived in the fall of 2004
taking a big chance by enrolling at a
new campus full of promise but with no
experience and I have to say as I stand
here four years later before you you
indeed have helped it succeed
brilliantly creating your own traditions
and building connections to the
Pittsburgh camp is more rapidly and more
completely than we dreamed was possible
we will always remember you for what you
have contributed to Carnegie Mellon but
I hope that you will always remember
what you have derived from this
experience some of this is apparent to
you now but some of it will only become
clear to you over time as you move into
your lives after college and your
careers you'll come to appreciate how
well prepared you are for the challenges
that lie ahead
indeed you are better prepared than any
graduating class in the world how do I
know this you might ask I know this
because I hear it from our alumni who
tell me this again and again they tell
me how their Carnegie Mellon education
prepared them well no matter what they
did after graduation or even much later
in life I know it because employers tell
me how ER they are to hire Carnegie
Mellon graduates because of their superb
skills and their readiness to get to
work from day one and those same
employers are never disappointed when
they hire our graduates and I know it
because you received an outstanding
education from some of the best most
brilliant most creative minds anywhere
we demand a lot from you and you know
that to be true Carnegie Mellon does not
teach waterdown courses your Carnegie
Mellon degree says to the world that you
have achieved something very meaningful
and very important but what you learn
here goes beyond what went on in your
classrooms and assignments you also
learned a way of working a set of values
and a framework for understanding the
world and for acting in the world you
learned about problem solving about
interdisciplinary collaboration and
teamwork and how to interact and learn
from people different from you you learn
about research and innovation and how to
be entrepreneurial and yes without a
doubt you learn a lot about hard work
and to say at the same time you discover
your capacity to do more than you
probably thought possible these core
values are the foundation of a Carnegie
Mellon education
we are committed to these values because
this is the way to prepare yourself to
have an impact on the world on guitar on
this region this indeed is the key to
being prepared for the rest of your
lives and the world needs people like
you people deeply trained with a command
of an area of knowledge comfortable
working across disciplines and cultures
ready to think creatively to find
innovative solutions to tough problems
and prepare to do what it takes to get
the job done and to do it well this is
the Carnegie Mellon way and it is now
your way
as you make the transition from being
students to becoming alumni remember
that you are still very much part of a
global community of more than 70,000
people who share your values and energy
and drive to make a difference I
especially hope that you as the first
graduates from this campus will take an
active role in this network you will
meet some fantastic people better still
they'll meet you carnegie mellon
university is very very proud to call
you our alumni congratulations